[Musique]
gilbert annette maire de saint-denis
accueilli cyrille melchior président du
département pour signer le pacte de
solidarité territoriale ce jeudi 30 août
un budget de près de 7 millions d'euros
est attribuée au chef lieu
c'est un coup d'accélérateur c'est de
l'oxygène financière et vous comprenez
bien que dans cette période de
restrictions budgétaires c'est c'est
très bien venu ça nous permet
d'accélérer par exemple la construction
de deux gymnases de mieux équiper les
écoles d'augmenter le quota de repas que
nous portions aux personnes âgées on va
passer 280 400 donc d'accélérer nos
actions sur des publics qui concerne à
la fois la ville et le département le
public en détresse et que pour nous
c'est c'est un vrai coup d'accélérateur
et c'est bien sûr très bienvenu on en
avait besoin et nous sommes très heureux
de signer ce partenariat un engagement
sur la période 2018 2020 les deux
institutions vont mutualiser leurs
moyens sur des projets communs quand je
signe avec le maire de saint denis
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que nous
plaçons l'éducation au coeur de nos
priorités et on l'a vu je le mets à
parler du rôle de la famille du rôle
aussi des écoles dans l'éducation la
formation et bien c'est une priorité
aussi paul département la réussite
scolaire fait partie de nos priorités
c'est pour cela que nous avons accordé
un large volet tourné vers l'école
l'école de la réussite dans ce pacte de
solidarité
si tu ajoutes signature le maire de
saint denis le président du département
se sont rendus à l'école damas le gros à
cinq meetings ou eric à barèges députée
conseillère
c'est pas les a rejoint ils ont pu
rencontrer des éducateurs spécialisés
qui aide les jeunes à sortir de l'échec
scolaire et sociale en partenariat signé
ce jour permettra de recruter de
nouveaux éducateurs
[Musique]